determine 7 30 45 abós y 54 82 son
fracciones equivalentes y bueno para ver
si dos fracciones son equivalentes o no
a mí lo que me parece que es lo más
fácil es escribir a las dos fracciones
en sus términos más simples ok donde el
numerador y el denominador sean lo más
chicos que pueden ser entonces pues
hagamos eso y si al final estas dos
fracciones son iguales entonces las dos
fracciones si son equivalentes y si son
distintas como el numerador y el
denominador son lo más pequeño que
pueden ser entonces esas dos fracciones
no son equivalentes
así es que pues empecemos por
transformar a 30 45 a bosch en la forma
más simple que se pueda okay veamos cuál
es el factor más grande que divide tanto
a 30 como a 45
pues es quincena entonces esta fracción
es igual a 2
por 15 entre 3 por 15 ahora qué pasa si
vivimos entre 15 tanto el numerador como
el denominador a ver vamos a dividir
entre 15 y entre 15 pues como estamos
dividiendo entre 15 al numerador y al
denominador entonces no estamos
afectando a la fracción es exactamente
igual a la que tenemos aquí sin embargo
este 15 con este 15 se cancela al igual
que por acá multiplicar por 15 y dividir
entre 15 es igual a multiplicar por 1
entonces se cancela y lo que nos queda
es simplemente dos tercios dos tercios y
ahora si no hay forma de hacer que el
numerador y el denominador sean más
chicos ok
esta es la forma simplificada de 3045 a
vos
shanghai 30 45 a vos es exactamente
igual a dos tercios nada más que lo
estamos escribiendo en una forma
simplificada entonces
vamos con 54 entre 81 y 54 entre 81 y
mira la verdad es que no me salta a la
vista exactamente cuál es el factor más
grande que divide a estos dos números
entonces pues vamos a empezar por
factores más pequeños y así vamos
dividiendo hasta que ya no podemos
dividir más entonces a ver según yo el 9
divide tanto 54 81 entonces por aquí 54
es igual a 6 por 9 y el denominador 81
es igual a 9 por 9 ahora te puedes
imaginar perfectamente qué voy a hacer
no o sea lo que voy a hacer aquí es
dividir el numerador y el denominador
entre 9 y para qué estoy haciendo eso
pues porque este 9 entre 9 es igual a 1
entonces se cancela por aquí y lo mismo
pasa por acá 9 entre 9 es igual a 1
estos dos se cancelan y nos quedan 6
entre 9 a ver ya ahora cuál es el factor
que divide tanto a 6,9 pues el 3 y los
divide a los 2 no entonces podemos
escribir esta fracción como 6 es igual a
2 por 3
y 9 es igual a tres por tres así es que
vamos a dividir entre tres arriba y
abajo pero bueno esto lo podemos
escribir también como multiplicar por un
tercio al numerador y el denominador
cierto aunque bueno como la verdad no
quiero asumir que sabes cómo multiplicar
fracciones porque lo vamos a ver más
adelante entonces déjame lo escribo de
la otra forma como lo hemos estado
haciendo ahorita que es dividir entre 3
arriba y abajo dividida entre 3 y
multiplicar por un tercio es exactamente
lo mismo el chiste es que dos por tres
entre tres el 3 entre 13 cancela 3 por 3
entre 3 3 entre 13 es igual a 1 entonces
nos queda 2 entre 3
entre 3 y 54 81 2 es exactamente igual a
dos tercios ya llegamos a la forma
simplificada de 54 entre 81 porque no
hay ningún número mayor que 1 que divida
tanto a 2,3 y qué crees que llegamos a
lo mismo que en esta otra fracción
entonces estas dos fracciones cuando las
simplificamos terminan siendo iguales
así es que en efecto estas dos
fracciones son fracciones equivalentes